there is very rarely any good news
coming out of china they are our number
one enemy
on the world stage they're challenging
all of our interests they basically own
our economy they own a number of our
politicians that's bad stuff
but occasionally on the cultural front i
think we could really learn a thing or
two from them
especially in the way that they are
taking the nyang pao out of their movies
no more nyong pao what is in young pal
i don't really know but from what i what
i have learned on the internet it is a
girly man no more girly men in chinese
movies here to help us make sense of all
of this
is megan basham the daily wire
entertainment reporter movie critic
author of beside every successful man
and and someone who is certainly not a
neon pow she is a a girl you're not a
man at all megan thank you for being
here
thank you for having me yeah no no [ __ ]
girls here
so so megan this is this is one of those
news stories that
i think confuses people who are used to
a traditional left right divide because
the right tends not to like communist
china the left tends to like communist
china
but
the left tends to like to promote [ __ ]
men or girly men or nyong pao and the
right tends to think that we ought to be
like gary cooper you know we ought to we
ought to go back to a time when men were
men
and yet china is the one putting out
this
fairly conservative or traditional uh
new cultural guideline for their movies
so how do we make sense of it
well you know it's it's kind of um you
need to look at it in the full context
of everything that china is doing
culturally so when you hear that the
chinese regulation board for
broadcasters has put out a ban on [ __ ]
men your instinct is probably to think
oh they're talking about gay men they're
talking about homosexuality well that
has actually been illegal on chinese
television since 2016.
so this is something bigger they're not
just saying we're not just going to have
homosexuality on television we don't
want um anything that confuses gender we
don't want
womanly effeminate looking men um you
might think for example of the
cinderella movie that amazon just
premiered with billy porter in the role
of a genderless fairy godmother well
that would be illegal now in china
do you do you know this actually brings
up
i think an even
more complicated aspect of the story
which is i didn't see the announcement
about the new cinderella movie with the
transgender godmother and i didn't see
it i had no idea why but then i looked i
clicked on the amazon prime video
account amazon prime video
blocked me on twitter now i thought
did you see that so i don't it's not as
though i were tweeting at them i i was
not interacting with them at all they
went out of their way to block me i like
to think it means that they do not
consider me a neonpow i'll flatter
myself here but it's it is very strange
because
we're looking now at a government-run
censorship board in china and so we say
well that's very bad we don't like that
but we have a sort of censorship system
here in the united states and we've
complained about that in hollywood for a
long time if you want a portrayal of
patriotism if you want a portrayal of
traditional values you're probably not
going to find that in hollywood and
maybe it's not run by the government but
it is run by the people who make the
movies
well and it's really interesting what's
happening with china in this new band
because it has
it has complicated things for hollywood
as you said they like to make a big show
of their representation and their
inclusivity but they tend to do it for
these big international movies your
marvels your star wars
they will
kind of throw themselves a parade for
their exclusively gay moments but
they're so small and they're so in the
background and their characters are like
i don't even know who that is
and then they go overseas and they can
easily cut those scenes and they they
keep them very small so that china may
be willing to overlook it because
something else to know about this is
that china is now the number one movie
market in the world uh they passed us
last year so you have hollywood going
gosh we really want all that chinese
money but we also want all the accolades
over here in the u.s from glad
and other gay groups that they work very
closely with so um it's it's really
become a very sort of complicated and
for me kind of an amusing situation to
watch well it's funny you mention this
that when the left when hollywood puts
its really progressive moments they
always seem to be kind of contained so
that maybe you could edit them out
because i last year a friend of mine
said michael
you have to watch this new cartoon movie
i said why i'm not gonna i'm an adult
i'm not gonna watch i said you have to
watch it it's one of the best movies to
come out in years it's called the
mitchells versus the machines
and it was this move it's real it's
a movie totally about family values
tradition
loving your community fighting against
the big tech oligarchs i mean
jack dorsey is basically the villain in
this movie and and a good suburban
father is sort of the hero and
the movie is as conservative as anything
i've ever seen except there is one
totally gratuitous woke moment at the
very end during the credits i mean it's
so
but you know it
i imagine they couldn't have made the
movie without that it wouldn't have
gotten out of hollywood and yet if a
movie like that were to go to china you
could very easily edit it out so what is
what is this going to mean for the big
tent poles the marvel movies the the the
movies where the the woke focus is on if
china says you're out of here
well i mean there's a couple of
possibilities and you know i'm not a
prophet so i can just give you sort of
the lay of the land as i see it and one
of the things that you're going to see
is you you're seeing a lot of strife
within some of these studios you hear
rumors that marvel chief kevin feige has
gone to war with some of the disney
chiefs because for that reason he's out
there promising representation and
they're out there looking at the bottom
line um so you're seeing a lot of
internal strife i think um
i think you're gonna see
a lot of
uncomfortable let me put it this way um
opinion essays that are starting to run
in a lot of the trade magazines and i
don't want to be explicit here on the
ben shapiro show but i mean
i have seen essays from
gay activists complaining that yes you
had a gay love scene
but you didn't show
thrusting that is an actual essay that
ran so i'm just telling you that ran and
so you're seeing that's always my
complaint i'm sorry to interrupt you but
that's i say you need more thrusting in
your
scenes i'm sorry to bring it up but that
was a very big very real essay that ran
um dealing with at that point they were
talking about rocket man
uh elton john biopic yeah so um so
you're starting to see this really big
clash of values and when you look at
what china is doing
with the video game ban i don't know if
you've talked about this but the video
they're not allowing kids to play video
games more than three hours a week
with this ban on again not just
homosexuality
but effeminacy they don't want girly
weak young men you look at these two
cultures and you go which one's gonna
dominate on the world stage
um
it doesn't feel like it's going to be
the one with the genderless fairy
godmother
this is the issue if the the biggest
cause that america can rally around is
is
the number of thrusts that we can insert
into gay movies then i i just think
china invade us now this is we're not
going to put up a defense this is so
weak and
this also requires i think a little bit
of historical perspective because
while the united states we always love
to talk about freedom in the abstract
and you do whatever you want and that's
the american way nothing more american
than more thrusts in movies that
actually is that isn't the case you know
we had an industry code called the haze
code for many years and rather than
stifled the creativity of the movies you
know you had the greatest movies ever
made were made during this era i think
just one year just 1939 sort of at the
height of the haze code you had gone
with the wind the wizard of oz
stagecoach mr smith goes to washington
wuthering heights i mean the list goes
on and on and on and now we produce what
a bunch of
swill basically a bunch of of weak
movies that when you look at the oscars
most people haven't even seen or heard
of most of them so what does this mean
for hollywood i mean is hollywood going
to learn any lessons about maybe the
sorts of values people want to see in
movies or
or no or they or you know it seems to me
that the movies are less and less
relevant every year or they are they
just going to persist in this
well and you know that's an interesting
question because you look at it and you
go don't they like money don't they like
having big box office returns and
they've been getting their money in
large part overseas so if that spigot
turns off are they going to have to
actually start appealing to american
average american audiences because you
do look at it you go so many of these
studio chiefs so many of these
filmmakers directors producers they seem
to want the applause of their industry
more than they want big hits and it
really doesn't make a lot of sense just
from a dollars and cents point of view
but if you look at it from
cultural cred
you know that they really like to have
within their group and that's a powerful
force and i think it's really hard to
overcome it but
if china is no longer allowing american
movies in and they have really curtailed
the number of us films they're letting
in
that could reshuffle the deck in some
ways and you might start to see
maybe some upstart particularly um
production companies entertainment
companies come in
and offer
some of the types of entertainment that
families are dying for and they are
dying for it i mean it was really
frustrating to me to see that mitchell's
versus the machines and get all the way
through it and then in the credits very
last scene she refers to a girlfriend
and i'm sitting there with my
seven-year-old going this did not just
happen yeah we made it through an hour
and 29 minutes of this excellent movie
and then for no reason you throw in this
this radical sort of partisan statement
i know it was it was the same it was the
same feeling that i had and it now it's
the most scandalizing thing of all i
guess is that
the average american movie watcher
seems to have more in common
with the chinese communist party in
terms of what we want to see on screen
than we do with the people running
hollywood
i mean that is bizarre right that tells
you
how strange these sort of little um
insular communities can become that i'm
like you need to
listen to the rest of the country a
little bit and here's the thing though i
don't think that they don't know i mean
come on they they know what movies are
in big box office they know that part of
the reason that your superhero movies do
so well isn't because people only like
superhero movies it's because they're
designed for an international audience
and therefore they don't have a lot of
the content not none but again it's
usually very subtle so
they know that that will make a lot of
money and that's why parents go to it
that's what because i can take my kid to
see thor i can take my kid to see
captain america at this point still and
not worry too much about what kind of
content is going to be in it wait you're
saying you didn't take your kid to see
moonlight or call me by their name or
what i mean
you know
it was a tough call but i went she's a
little young at 7 11. i'm not going to
do that and forget the kids versus just
a lot of americans generally wouldn't
wouldn't go see these movies and so i i
suppose there's a little bit of hope
here that of all places the chinese
communists are going to be doing it you
know we've only got about 30 seconds
left but i do have to ask for your
thoughts on
why now why is the chinese communist
party now pushing for these more
relatively traditional values and more
patriotic movies
well that's kind of a scary question
isn't it because yeah why now if as you
brought up if china owns so much of our
economy if um suddenly the world has
become much more unstable and they are
starting to dominate major industries
like the entertainment industry and
become the biggest box office in the
world well gee you know maybe they're
suddenly starting to think we need to
have um a populace that is
ready to dominate the world stage if the
us is declining that's the scary thing
even beyond whatever movies you're going
to see and whatever woke moments at the
end of mitchells versus the machines
who's the top dog who's calling the
shots well
china seems to think it's no longer the
united states megan we got to leave it
there thank you so much for being here
get megan's book too beside every
successful man and uh you can always
read her stuff on the daily wire as new
smaller
growing companies start to take on
entertainment as well megan thank you
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment